plastic waste drifting in the water
filming that revealed the damage being
done by our throwaway culture
there is a worldwide brussel production
of 350 million tons
per year and about 300 million tons are
ending up
as a waste
it's hard to believe but this is
actually a river
we've put billions of tons actually of
plastic into the environment
by 2050 people have predicted that
there'll be more plastic in the ocean
than fish in terms of weight
remnants of our products have spread to
every corner of the planet
plastics are in the food we eat and the
water we drink
with both global production of plastics
and the cost of recycling rising
the outlook is bleak
but our planet has a remarkable way of
fighting back
recently discovered plastic eating
bacteria has given scientists hope
hope to decontaminate our planet and
make cleaner products for the future
[Music]
plastics take the stage at an
international exhibit in amsterdam
the ingenious alchemy of coal and oil
provides the material
ingenious machinery presses and stamps
and molds the material
into a wide variety of products articles
for household use
as well as tools for industry strong
light cheap easy to clean
quite simply plastic is a miracle
material
in the world of tomorrow plastics will
certainly call the tune
the beginning of the 20th century saw a
revolution in production
and it's changed our lives for the
better in immeasurable ways
everything has to be of plastic even
furniture was created of plastic
until the 1970s
it saves lives it stops us getting sick
it gets us from a to b
not a day goes by without near total
dependence on it
from our clothes our shoes to our phones
and as the slogan for the first fully
synthetic plastic claimed it really is a
material of a thousand uses
before becoming totally ubiquitous such
products seemingly lasted forever
but that advantage from 50 years ago is
now a dangerous flaw
the plastic coffee cup we use for a
couple of minutes will stay in our
environment for hundreds
if not thousands of years without
decomposing
it's estimated more than eight billion
tons of plastic has been produced
since the 1950s
in 2016 a team of japanese scientists
made a discovery
that had the potential to turn the tide
in the fight against plastic
were scraping around in the soil and
wastewater runoff of our recycling
facility in japan they actually found a
bacteria
that remarkably was living off the
plastic bottles themselves
so they took that back to the lab and
they were able to culture it
just feeding it a diet of plastic p-e-t
plastic that's the plastic for um
bottles and clothing
and carpets and that sort of thing so
it's a very common plastic in the
environment
they've evolved to eat various types of
food sources
and um what seems to be happening in
that that rubbish dump in japan
is that they're secreting a couple of
enzymes and those enzymes
actually break apart the polymer chain
and the plastic
providing molecules as food professor
john mcgehen and his team at portsmouth
university in the uk
are one of several groups around the
world now investigating the potential of
plastic eating bacteria
so to understand the process of how this
works we kind of need to understand what
a polymer is
so pet plastic is an incredibly common
plastic in the environment
and it's made of two building blocks one
called ethylene glycol and the other
called terethalic acid
and basically these building blocks are
kind of held together
by bonds called esther bonds so then you
get poly
lots of esther polyester and this is our
plastic
so if you look on your clothing you'll
probably see a label saying polyester
that's all it is is those building
blocks linked together in long chains to
create these plastics
and all an enzyme needs to do is come
along and snip
those bonds like big pair of molecular
scissors and then you get the building
blocks back again
so you've found a bacteria that's living
in a rubbish dump
how do you then get enzymes out of it
actually these days it's very simple
you grow the bacteria in the lab and
then coding within that bacteria is dna
it's like a four letter code
that codes for the it's like the
instruction manual for that enzyme
we can pull that out and make it
synthetically in the lab these are the
two
individual enzymes that are produced by
that bacteria in the rubbish dump
and found in japan and what we did in
the laboratory
is take those two separate enzymes uh
the first one
is called petties and the second one is
called inhetas and we physically linked
them together to make this
chimeric enzyme and we found that this
one
was around six times faster than the
original natural enzyme that we
originally studied
so what we can show here is that we can
take some learnings from nature
take them back to the lab and then adapt
things to make them faster
and more efficient which is what we need
if we're going to have a
economically viable recycling solution
enzymes are really ubiquitous in nature
and they're used for making things and
breaking things so the human body is
full of enzymes
we use enzymes every day and our
biological washing powders they contain
those powdered enzymes that can break
down grass stains and their
food stains um so we're actually as a
technology it's very mature
so then turning enzymes towards problem
materials like plastics really seems
like a sensible way forward
the sorts of enzymes we're using today
in the food industry in the
pharmaceutical industry
they were also very slow when they were
first discovered
and over years of generations we've
managed to improve them to be in some
cases
a hundred or even a thousand times
faster than the original
natural variants so this gives us hope
the dream is to produce industrial
quantities of enzyme which can be
freeze-dried
and turned into a powder this would then
be poured over to break down the waste
products
what you're left with is a clear
solution of monomers
these are the building blocks that you
would originally get from oil and gas
and they're exactly the same
except this time you can do it over and
over again in
infinite circular economy style and this
is where we want to get to
currently the enzymes are too slow to be
economically viable you're dealing with
pet plastic but
there's plenty of other types aren't
there so
does that complicate recycling pet is
around maybe 20
of the plastic out there but we also
have lots of other types of plastic
polyethylene plastic bags polypropylene
for
for harder plastics pvc many many
different types
and of course this is the problem if
you're a recycling facility
you need a way to sort through these and
pull out value for from these
materials and that's a real challenge
and this is what we're struggling with
we tend to demonize plastics but
actually it's not
how we use them it's how we dispose of
them that's the real issue
we've never been that good at recycling
even before the pandemic
when major corporations like danone and
coca-cola were pledging to increase
recycled plastics in their packaging
only about nine percent of all plastic
ever produced has been made into
something new
it's rather disconcerting that less than
10 of plastic bottles are actually
recycled back into plastic bottles
part of the reason for that is economics
the falling price of oil has compounded
the problem
it's meant it's become much cheaper to
make brand new plastic
so manufacturers have less incentive to
use recycled materials
companies really want to use recycled
material but it's expensive and it's
often a poor quality
that's because if you mechanically
recycle pet or other plastics
if you've got any contaminants colors
and things basically the
material loses its material properties
each time you do it
so even though people when they put
those bottles in the green bin think
it's going to turn back into a bottle
often it's down cycled and it's it's on
a sad path to landfill
in leipzig germany another team of
scientists are working with plastic
eating enzymes
they're targeting polyurethane a plastic
of complex chemistry
so there are four five six different
monomers
in polyurethane we have the keyword
urethane bones which are very very
complex
and very stable yeah therefore we use
that stings for
our shoe soles yeah we don't want that
after 10
kilometers of running the shoes are
broken
sneakers are products that are often
made up of multiple types of plastics
when products are made like this it can
make it much harder and less economical
to recycle
while their work in breaking down
polyurethane or pu
is an important step dr hi piper
actually sees the best application
in making plastic not any old plastic
though
material that breaks down once used
that means changing how we make things
like creating sneakers that use
just one species of plastic which are
less chemically stable
and therefore better at biodegrading so
the dream of this magic bacteria that
eats all of the plastic
that's not close to reality you don't
think no not really no
normally these bacteria don't survive in
the dump site yeah so the
the lab rats don't survive in the real
environment and that means that cannot
be the the
the idea behind our research the
question for us microbiologists
uh is not to solve the problem of
waste by biological solution what we
call bioremediation
this cannot be the answer yeah but we
the answer must be
that we get a kind of picture
what kind of plastic and plastic waste
respectively is degradable in order to
give the politicians
and then we got go to big science to
give the politicians a kind of advice
what to stop and what not to stop
if you can develop a process where you
can break that plastic down again
there's plenty of it there's there's no
feedstock problem
and you have a low energy and low carbon
roots to doing that
you can start generating those monomers
those building blocks competitively
i can see there being a massive economic
switch is it doesn't need to be
on a level par it just needs to be close
and then suddenly
you have an opportunity there where
businesses can jump in
and make an awful lot of money i would
say um using those technologies to feed
a growing market let's not kid ourselves
plastic is
going to keep growing and if we can have
recycled feedstocks in the mix
that's that's one reason that's one way
to bring down
the co2 in the carbon budget
[Music]
the problem of plastic waste is now very
much in the mainstream
and the cause has support all over the
world
but our planet is at a critical moment
as its use
continues to grow innovations like
enzymes from plastic eating bacteria
could help re-imagine
the entire system
you